Well let's go back and remember our rule for shifting.
It only applies if we have a dot
in front of a token,
so we have sort of 2 possible worlds here: this has a dot
in front of nothing, and this has a dot in front of a token.
We are definitely going to use the dot in front of the token.
And then we need to look at that token,
and it better match the next part of the input.
So we haven't seen anything yet--is the next token an open parenthesis?
Oh, it is! We're so happy, this is going to work out perfectly.
So then, conceptually, what I do is just
shift my finger over one, just a step to the right.
So let's go see which one of those that looks like.
It should have this dot moved in, inside the parentheses.
Well, this does not quite match.
It doesn't have the parentheses at all--this represents using the wrong rule.
Over here, we've got the right rule,
but we didn't move the dot.
This is just the parse state we started with previously.
So that's not the result of shifting.
This, however--this is looking very promising.
We've moved the dot over one--
so now it's inside,
and we haven't changed this starting offset.
We're going to put this in chart[1],
and this information assumes we started with zero tokens .
Then we saw this left parenthesis and Here's where we are now.
Finally, in this last one,
We've mistakenly updated the starting position
or the (from) information,
and this would correspond to some other hypothetical input
where we had already seen one token,
and now we've seen one more open parenthesis
and we're expecting to see a few more.
That's not the input we're currently given.
This doesn't match--there are no hidden tokens
to the left that aren't shown in the rule.